actually I'm talking about something
different from what my original so they
yeah by original abstract it was
basically by open problem from yesterday
I decided to change my mind so to talk
about something else with a talker so
apologies what so financially coloring
and so this is joint work with Oded SRAM
and David Wilson hospital hardly
necessary to say with this audience Oded
SRAM was the central figure of his
generation in probability theory
probably and he passed away in a tragic
accident hiking extent in 2008 and David
and I took a rather embarrassing a long
time to finish this paper but it is now
finished so what's this all about well
proper coloring of a graph you all know
what this is you have a graph and you
want to label the vertices with some
colors which are just say integers 1 up
to you in such a way that adjacent
vertices have different colors so for
instance if you have z2 then if all you
want to do is color it that of course
you can do it with two colors in a
checkerboard so the kind of question I
want to think about is how could we
color with no central authority I mean I
want to imagine that each vertex is an
individual agent somehow and there's no
dictator it's just a democracy and they
want to come up with the coloring on
their own somehow okay so um well let's
try to make that precise I mean one
thing you could certainly ask for is
stationary colorings so random color
veins that are invariant and
distribution translation invariant and
distribution I mean that's certainly
saying somehow the rules are the same
everywhere so that would be a good start
and but of course that's still not a
very interesting question yet because on
z2 well there if I have two colors
they're exactly
22 colorings of course there's the red
blue checkerboard in the blue red
checker boat and if you want a
stationary coloring then of course you
have to just take that with probability
half and that's probability half but
this isn't very satisfying because it
has very long-range correlations I mean
to infinitely long if I know what color
this vertex is that I know the whole
coloring make sure they are able to use
well okay i'm going to die just as a
sort of warming up with the motivation
and then i'll be very very precise in a
second so yeah in the other direction
okay I sort of said I want my vertices
to be independent agents somehow now in
the extreme case you could say maybe
vertices have iid colors but of course
then you just can't get a proper
coloring there's some color that has
positive probability so you make it to
name is the same but then you could ask
about approximate independence can you
can the colors be somehow approximately
or as Matata CLE independent and cost
there are many many notions trivial
tales decay of collections etc any
questions you could ask but I'm going to
focus on something very specific here's
what I want to do and this is somehow
closest to the original I think closest
to the original thing i said i want the
vertices to behave like independent
agents and that can communicate with
each other though so so here's the
definition so a process index by let's
say it ZD although you can note more
generally a person says a finite or a
factor of an iid process which I will be
Victor ffi ID if and so first of all you
have an IAD protest process index by the
vertices U V and X Y the vertices of
said D any I I due process and the
process i'm interested in x is a
deterministic function of that so all
the randomness comes from just iid coin
flips or whatever at the individual
vertices and the map from you to X is
translation equivariant which it just
means it's the same everywhere so formal
it means if you take any translation of
I mean let's focus on Z if you take any
translation of ZD then it commutes with
the function so if
you were to shift all your coin flips to
the right by one and apply a rule again
you would end up with all the exits
shifted to the right back one it's very
natural so it's just saying it's the
same rule everywhere it doesn't treat
the origin in a special way or anything
like that and finally the most
interesting part and I want the the map
to be fine i tree so what does that mean
it means if you want to know the the
color at the origin say X 0 then it's
kind of like a stopping time the the
rule that determines it is of the form
you look at your iid randomness at the
odor in the origin looks as its own iid
random variable and then depending on
what it sees maybe it looks at the iid
randomness of the neighbors and then
depending on what it sees there maybe it
looks at the next nearest neighbors and
so on but after some finite but random
and perhaps unbound it's time or radius
it knows what color it should be ok so
that's what this has formally that x0 is
determined by the Yuuzhan some ball or
box that doesn't matter i'm not going to
care about which metric particularly for
some random radius and formally that's
what it means to be determined ok ok so
that's the definition and that's what i
want to focus on so the the basic
question is going to be does there exist
an FFI ID coloring and if and then if so
we have this quantitative question we
have this coding radius which is this
random distance that you have to look to
to determine the color at the origin how
small can we make that random variable
and just to warm up again on deal with
with two colors the answer is no because
the only stationary coloring is this to
checkerboards with probability half and
it's very easy to see that that's not of
this form so it's not even mixing as a
random process and also you can't do it
with r equals zero because that means
you just have I ID random variables and
you can't do
coming that way and I won't dwell on
this but but this is very closely
related to applications in distributed
computing so you should imagine that you
have a network of machines computers and
distributed computing is all about you
know using networks of machines to solve
actual computational problems global
problems without any central authority
somehow but I mean this is asking
something even simpler just asking them
to solve a local problem it's just
asking them to not disagree with each
other to find a proper coloring of
themselves and if you want an actual
application of that you can imagine that
the colors represent update schedules or
communication frequencies or something
for individual computers and you want
neighbors to be not in conflict with
each other so you want to proper
coloring and let's get that to math so
I'm going to focus on set d ZD so here's
a warm-up example that you can do this
think here's an example of an FFI ad for
coloring of the two-dimensional lattice
z2 and it's going to have exponential
tails of this coding radius so here's
one where you can do that first of all
each so the the vertices are going to be
squares here first of all each vertex
just tosses a coin the probability half
its black or white and so that gives you
some black and white squares now from
percolation theory you know that site
percolation on the square lattice the
critical probability is strictly greater
than a half so a half is subcritical so
it means you have black clusters and
white clusters and they are finite and
better than that they have pretty small
diameter so the diameter of the cluster
at zero has exponentially decaying tails
so now what I'm going to do of course
this is not a proper coloring if I want
to pop a coloring I can check about I
can check aboard each white cluster in
red and blue say
and I can check about each black cluster
in green and yellow say and and that
clearly gives me a for coloring and why
is it FF I ad well you have to think of
it from the point of view of this local
rule right so I'm sitting at the origin
what do I have to do to determine my
color well I didn't quite tell you how
to do this because because they're there
are two possible red blue checker boards
on a white cluster and I have to decide
between them so one way to do it is just
start from the northeast corner of the
cluster the lexicographically largest
point in the cluster and say that guy's
where and say so okay so if I'm the
origin and I want to know my color what
do I have to do well first of all I have
to explore my cluster and find out i'm
in a black or white cluster i have to
find out what it is and then i have to
telephone the guy in the northeast
corner and find out my piratey relative
to him and then I know what color I
should be and how far do I have to look
to determine my color well it's the it's
the radius of the cluster basically
which has exponential tails okay and by
the way one wrinkle here is this
satisfies what I said it's a translation
equivariant function but somehow I broke
some symmetry by saying look in the
northeast corner so it's not rotation
invariant or reflection invariant so
actually if you want to you can make it
isometry equivariant and one way to do
that is in addition to these black and
white labels each vertex pics say a
uniform 01 random variable and
independently so the randomness consists
of the coin flips and the 01 render
bevel and then rather than saying that
the northeast corner of the cluster
determines the parity I'll say just the
largest uniform and available on the
cluster determines it look for the
largest rope so that's rotation and
reflection component as well
okay so obvious questions are can we
yeah that letter distribution how far is
that from the uniform distribution of
four colorings very long way away yes
nothing like it well depends how you
measure but if you draw a picture of
area it won't look listen I mean the
clusters in you know there they have
exponential tails but they're not
trivial this model you'll be able to
tell which is the red blue and which is
the green yellow so questions can we do
better can we make so this was already
pretty good in some sense because i only
used for colors and my our was nice and
verbal with exponential tails but maybe
i could be bounded so it would be far
better why not and of course what about
other dimensions and what about other
numbers of colors so more colors makes
things easier but could I do this with
three colors for example okay so it
turns out on Z D we have pretty much all
the answers here at least in a certain
sense and the answers are quite
surprising so Z D with D greater than or
equal to 2 so what about three colors
well you can do it with three colors so
there does exist a FF i-83 coloring and
it has a power-law tail the probability
radius is greater than our bubble you
have to go further distance and decays
like at least a power law and you can't
do better than a power loss so any FFA a
d3 coloring has infinite second moment
of our and unfortunately all we can
prove is this a is very very small it's
positive but very close to zero so
there's actually a big gap between two
and a so we don't know what the correct
power is that's a very interesting
restaurant but at least with three
colors it's a power law and you can't do
any better than a parallel
and okay so that's the colors what about
four colors so I asked can you do better
than an exponential tail well the answer
is you can you can do something quite
extraordinary actually so there is a for
coloring with much better than
exponential tails it's at our function
tail so the probability you have to go
greater than listens out is it's not
just doubly exponentially small it's one
over at our of Exponential's of height
about our okay so that's pretty much
what net so it's very very nearly a
bounded random variable in some sense
for tactical purposes expended so can
you do any better well no actually this
is this is tight in the sense that for
four or more colors there's a lower
bound of the same form a different
constant which of course makes a big
difference with functions like this okay
so three colors you can do parallel four
or more colors you can do this
remarkable tower function and that's the
best you can do and again this is for
all dimensions great an extra two and
one dimension is slightly different in
one dimension depending on D in one
dimension you don't have this power loss
phase anymore so it cost two colors you
can't do at all but already with three
colors in one dimension you can do it
with the tower function as the answers
and I will attempt to at least give you
an idea of how these things arise how
these different behaviors of ice okay so
simplest one to show you is here is how
to three color z2 ok so and now for some
reason the the vertices are actually the
intersections not the squares and so ok
if you have a three coloring of zitu and
you think about a unit square then if
you think about it for a second there
must be two diagonal point that are the
same color as each
because you only have three colors and
so I'm going to sort of use that fact so
I'm going to in each unit square I'm
going to draw a diagonal line that way
or that way with equal probabilities and
they're going to be iid coin flips okay
if you look at this picture what do you
have well z2 is bipartite and if you
look at the even sub lattice that the
green vertices and you look at the edges
that connect them these green edges then
use you simply have critical bond
percolation on z2 but it's easy to
tilted by 45 degrees because each
possible edge like this one is either
present or absent with probability half
and what about the other edges the
purple ones well they are exactly the
planar duel of the percolation
configuration the green percolation
configuration I have the percolation
configuration and it's dual and it's
critical critical percolation so the
clusters are finite the green cluster
than the purple clusters a finite but
they have power law tails so what I want
to do is assign a color to each cluster
and well that's good because these
clusters are composed of diagonal line
so I don't create any if I color this
purple cluster in red I don't create any
color conflicts there but of course what
I have to be careful with is that
there's an adjacent cluster like this
green one and that has to be a different
color and they have to be careful about
parity here because the way I drew it
the e odd and even lattices are sort of
regarded as different but they have to
treat them the same way otherwise
otherwise I might have every well have
just done a checkerboard to begin it
doesn't come and so never the best one
can do this so because its bond
percolation and it's dual each each
cluster green or purple is surrounded by
some cluster of the other color and and
vice versa so if you look at the
adjacency graph of clusters so each node
here is a cluster in the previous
picture and it's a one ended tree
so each each cluster is just surrounded
by some other phone a cluster and you
can keep going up as long as you want
them but when you go down the tree is
finite so that's what the tree looks
like it so all I have to do is three
color this tree and that shouldn't be
too hard i should be able to do that
with pretty good tales because it's a
tree and really only need two colors to
cover it so here's one way to do it so
first of all just toss coins color each
node cluster red with probability half
well of course that doesn't work because
maybe i have two adjacent ones that are
both red but now i delete the Reds whose
parent is also right so now at least I
don't have two adjacent red clusters and
then I'm just going to fill in in layers
so below of where they did have a layer
of blue and hilaire of green alternating
until I run into some more beds and then
I start again I mean there's many ways
to joke but this will do and and it
considered on this tree this somehow has
very good tales because all i need to do
if i want to know my color is i need to
go up to my first red parent and that's
an you know a geometric random variable
it has exponential tail suits are very
local somehow so that shouldn't
intuitively that shouldn't really hurt
my power law tales that i already have
on the size of clusters and if you want
to make that rigorous see you have to
work a bit more but but you can do it
with rissa see more welsh technology
from percolation and you get a parallel
bout that unfortunately the power is
probably small as as always using this
method okay so that's that and i said
actually we can do this in any dimension
so we can three color Zed d with power
law tails and the idea is this is much
much harder or at least the way we did
it was much much harder but the idea is
you start with a hierarchical partition
of ZD that somehow has the same tree
structure as the graph of clusters and
we construct this by some rather messy
business with random seeds and drawing
balls around them and growing things the
the cells of the partition are no longer
these
sings composed of diagonal lines that
the cells are actual solid lumps so I
can't assign a single color to each
solid lump because that wouldn't be a
coloring but what i can do is assign a
checkerboard coloring using two out of
the three colors to each cell and if you
think about it there are six possible
checkerboard color eggs using two out of
the three colors and a and certain pairs
of them are allowed to be next to each
other if I have a region colored like
this then it's ok to have a region next
to it colored like this because the the
greens are in the same place so I have
to assign a checkerboard to each cell in
such a way that they respect this this
rough and well you can do it again the
structure of the cells is a tree so it's
a similar sort of method each
to find these special cells at sort of
as before and then each special cell
thinks of its favorite checkerboard and
it tries to force its descendants to use
it so this is some sort of Archduke and
this is his favorite pattern so he
really wants that all is the modern it's
to use it but he has a problem he may
not be allowed to use it because there's
a king and a nympho and so on above him
so maybe he's forced to use this but
he's going to you know make damn sure
that everyone lower down uses it except
that he has to he has to work to it he
has to move along the graph of possible
checkerboards until he could reach that
one and then when you get to another
special vertex that gets to take over
the task so anyway you can do this ok so
that was that was three colorings into
with power law tells so why can I do no
better than power law tails well so here
is so I'm going to prove at least
describe the proof that any three
coloring on z2 in two dimensions the
coding radius has to have infinite
second moment and in fact it's enough to
prove this in two dimensions because
suppose you had a very good three
coloring in three dimensions well you
know with coding radius that's much
smaller I can restrict it to the plane
so then I have a coloring of z2 and that
is actually an FFI ad coloring on the
plane because I can everything comes
from these iid random variables that's
underlying everything and I can think of
the whole infinite column of iid random
variables that goes through the origin
as a single one that's located at the
origin so then I have a a really good
affinity coloring on the plane as well
so it's enough to do two dimensions and
in fact there's something much stronger
that's true so any stationary three
coloring has slowly decaying
correlations in some sense and it's a
power law that gives you this if you
translate it to the question I'm asking
and the reason is that there's a height
function for colorings 33 colorings in
that tube specifically and the height
what that means is
is a proper food coloring as Z to you
think of the color 2012 and the height
function is an integer valued function
such that neighbors differ by exactly 1
plus or minus 1 by the way and it's
equal to the color mod 3 okay so it
turns out you can do this to check there
is such a thing you really just have to
check that it works out around a unit
square and the I mean the height
function is determined by the coloring
except that you you have to choose the
height at the origin one free choice
other than that it's determined and the
point is that the height change around
any contour think of a large contour
must be zero and that's a problem
because that's it's a problem if you
want to do coloring in a very efficient
way with it with a small code egregious
because it's sort of a global constraint
so the proof is based on that and we
won't go into all the details but you
take a large contour and a very weak
condition just tailed to a reality of
the matter tells you that the variance
of the change in height along the side
of the square of the contour is large
and it comes from this level which is
quite an interesting lemmas over for
hardcore random processes people i'd be
interested if you've ever seen anything
like this before is sort of various ways
to prove it but I don't know whether
it's just an easy consequence of
something that's well not we weren't
able to find that and anyway if you if
you have an FFI ID coloring or if you
have any process with fast decay of
correlations then the idea is that you
expect changes along different sides of
this large square to be roughly
independent of each other so it means if
you just go around the the cycle you
shouldn't expect the the heights to join
up when you get to the beginning and
that would be a problem so
yep
okay so what about this so that was yeah
yeah nondeterministic so just the data
which is you uniform transitive three
adii thing you do you're talking about
this lemma so it's to see what is it is
as if you have any stationary sequence
plus or minus one minus and right tell
trivial and not deterministic yeah yes
every condition here is important that
then the since we've got this part and
then you look at the sum of the of these
variables from 1 to N and the variance
of that whole small King Valdemar
fastest well you know right now I mean I
are we doing a very interesting to just
understand this lemma more and what's
the strongest you can say I mean I don't
even know whether you can say limit
instead of limb soup I think and yes and
no it's not as no it's not no no almost
surely so it's just the variance
yeah I'd be very interested to come back
to that anyone who's interested alright
so that was the three coloring power-law
story now let's go to the other the even
more surprising sounding story the four
colors and tower functions so and
there's and i'll do the positive
direction first I'll show that you can
achieve these tower functions so that
the sort of key element that behind it
it is something that is known in the
distributed computing literature in fact
so the the earliest i know is a paper by
colon michigan in 86 that does something
like this the key ingredient that I need
so what's the idea and I'm going to show
you a reduction from and this is going
to be on Z for the time being just on
the line I'm going to show you a
reduction from labeling just means a
coloring except it need not be a proper
coloring labeling with 2 to the N colors
too far fewer and this is how it goes so
you have a just a sequence of integers
but you think of them as you know an
attempt at a coloring of ze that doesn't
quite work because maybe they're 25 secs
to each other and you write each number
in binary ok and then you do the
following you look at pairs adjacent
pairs and you go down and find the first
place where the two bits are different
going down and until you write down the
row that you had to go to to find two
things that are different and also which
way round they were this was 10 so great
in it and then they did the same thing
to these two very very strange thing to
do apparently but but but what it does
is certainly i reduced the number of
symbols from 2 to the N to about 2 N and
yeah there's one thing I didn't tell you
if the two things are the same then they
just have to have another symbol for
that
and where to start if the two symbols up
here were the same I just register so so
it very much reduces as the alphabet
size but it's it's no worse at being a
coloring so I get a color clash on the
bottom in other words i get two things
next to each other that are equal only
where I had a color clash above because
somewhere else if these three things are
all different then I don't write any
stars down here if those two were the
same it would mean though that it was
that both times the digits differed in
the second row say and they were both
1010 and that can't happen because this
would have to be both one and zip okay
so we're going strange about that but
that's the property it has so now the
idea is so start with just random random
symbols up here but with a huge alphabet
of billion symbols or something and then
do this reduction so now i have only a
thousand symbols and still by
probability of a color clash is no
bigger than it was before so it's one in
a billion and then i can do it again i
can do it k times and then i hugely
reduce the number of colors on the other
hand what does this have to do with FF i
ad well i started with an iid sequence
so if i do this K times to get this
process I only look at my two neighbors
so if they do it k times I've only
looked to distance k so if you do this K
times you get something with bounded are
it's just a block factor of an iid
process with just some fixed number of
colors six plus one because it mean if n
is small enough then that's not bigger
than that anymore so you have to stop
somewhere and and you get it's very new
their coloring the probability of a
color clash is something tiny involving
at our function and then I do of what
you do then is you somehow have to
stitch together these almost colorings
for different values of K I mean sort of
the idea is you have this process that
just very occasionally it makes a
mistake it has two colors the same
by looking to distance k so when i see
that i want to look one further i want
to look to distance k plus 1 and then
it'll be even less likely to have a
color clash so by doing this you can get
an FFI 86 coloring of the integers
perfect six hung and for instance then
you can easily get six to the D colors
on CD by taking products you do this on
every row and column and take the
product of them so that's why we're a
lot of colors but at least it's FFA OD
and so now you can reduce to the number
of you can reduce the number of colors
at least two degree plus 1 by an
elimination trick so here's six colors
on Z wherever I see color 6 i'm going to
delete it and replace it with something
else and what they replace it with is
the smallest color that's not one of its
two neighbors okay so then i get rid of
all the sixes at the expense of just
having everyone having to look maybe one
further out so that's quite good news
and I can keep on doing that until I
have three colors or in general for
general graph the degree plus 1 because
I have two neighbors so I might in heat
three colors to do this and then right
so that already tells you on Z you can
three color with the tower function
which is one of the things I claimed and
on z2 it tells you you can do it with
five colors and I claimed you can do it
with four colors so then there's another
you know really rather technical proof
where we managed to reduce all the way
down to four colors in CD and and it
goes via all sorts of reductions
long-range colorings maximal independent
sets so for this problem coloring is
somehow the same as maximal independent
sets they're sort of equivalent you can
go both ways between them and so we
managed to get a to labeling with
bounded clusters so black and white
clusters and each cluster just has size
at most 100 literally or something like
that and then you check about the
clusters just like I did at the
beginning and somewhere it's very
complicated but it all comes down to the
fact that nzd you can have two regions
meeting at a corner without actually
touching each other that's somehow
comes down to okay what about the lower
band so I claimed you can't do better
than this tower function which is a
pretty remarkable sounding claim so this
is a beautiful lemma it's one of these
things are it's a little bit difficult
to know exactly whom to attribute it to
so there's something again in the
distributed computing literature there's
a paper by mon lean or and 91 that
proves essentially this you can argue
it's really a version of ramses theorem
it's it's a probabilistic variant of
ramses them any case it is it's a lovely
lemma so it says I'm completely clean
slate here you can start again if you
have any iid random variables you I and
you have a function from our real
arguments to a finite space just
integers 1 up to q SE and you look at F
of U 1 up to you are and you look at F
of slide along by one you two up to you
r plus 1 and you ask whether those two
things are equal then the claim is with
positive probability they're equal and
then that's it's not obvious that it's
with positive probability at all but for
this i want the bound as well so not
only is the probability positive but
it's bounded below by something which is
incredibly small but positive it's a
tower of height about our and you have a
queue at the top and this is essentially
tight by essentially by the construction
i showed you a and so well at least
outline how you might prove this I'll
just prove that it's positive i won't
bother with the proving the tower
function so it's by induction on our
hours the length of the block i was 10
equals one is easy because then you just
have f of u 1 equals f of you two and
these are iid discrete random bubbles so
i'm going to shoot here's the key step
it's going to be by induction and here's
the key thing that you do here's a set
valued function of R minus one argument
I look it so here are my r minus 1
arguments Hey look at F i plug in those
r minus 1 numbers that you gave me and
then they let the last argument of FB
random just with the distribution that
these things are supposed to have that
gives me you know this F is now random
and I look at the values that can take
the values that can take out one up to Q
but maybe it doesn't take them all with
positive probability I look at the set
of ones that it can take social colors
that it can be with positive probability
that's a set it's a set that's a
function of you little you odd up to
little you r minus 1 and because it
takes a most to to the Q values because
it's a subset of one up to Q sohel I the
inductive hypothesis to that and natural
hypothesis says with positive
probability f of u 1 up to your r minus
1 where these things we learned them
again now equals slide the window along
by one and then okay what what so so
that means there's some particular set
such that with positive probability
they're both equal to that but what was
s well it's this set of values that F
can take with positive probability so f
of you on up to you are is in this set
and in particular that you can pick a
deterministic element of that set so
that with everything here is still true
with positive probability F equals that
as well and now I haven't looked at you
r plus one yet and by definition F every
element of this set a which equals this
s has a positive chance of being hit by
F of you two up to you r plus 1
including the site so with positive
probability this equals that induction
and if you believe that then then you
could sort of see where the tower
function might come from if I try to
make it quantitative quantitative
because when I reduced our by one i went
from Q colors to 22 the cute colors
fading the sour times right and so who
and why does that mean you can't beat
this tower function for FF I ad well you
know suppose you have an extraordinarily
good rule for coloring on ze say just
look at the places where you didn't have
to look further than distance k to
determine your color just look at those
colors so you'll get something if your
are is extraordinarily good better than
this tower function then you'll get
something that's almost too coloring
your probability of a color clash will
be phenomenally small even even smaller
than 1 over Tower and this lemma tells
you that that's impossible ok so how
long do I have 55 min two minutes ok so
very very quickly so just two other
directions that you can go both of which
are very interesting you can look at
shifts of finite type so coloring is a
local constraint but you can look at
general hard local constraints and the
term here is a shift of finite type so
shift of finite type just means you have
a finite number of colors on z DC and
but I tell you on 10 by 10 boxes there
are only this atlas of local patterns
that you're allowed to have so coloring
is an example of a thing like that but
you can have all sorts of others and
just a system of local constraint so in
one dimension we know what happens with
any local can straight there are two
trivial cases one trivial case is some
constant sequence is allowed and that
boeing then you don't need anyone wants
at all and the other trivial ish case is
where you have some kind of periodicity
like with two coloring and then you
can't do it at all you make you can't
even have a mixing process that
satisfies it and if otherwise it's the
answer is it's at our function tara
function upper and lower bounce so this
function is kind of universal in one
dimension in higher dimensions we don't
know you can you can have shifts of
finite type in higher dimensions and we
have these four cases the two trivial
ones and then we have power law cases
like three coloring we have tower
function cases like for coloring and I
don't know whether any of these three
gaps I've been sort of here is where
we're most used to working those
develops it is there any shift of finite
type where the best you could do is
exponential tales and I don't know
whether any of those three gaps contain
anything else so finally in 30 seconds
there's another very very interesting
direction you can go so if you have an
FF iid process where the coding radius
is bounded then that's something much
simpler that's a block factor that says
that that says you have a ID random
variables and think about one dimension
for now and you just have a fixed length
of block and the color at the origin
just depends on this block of K things
ok that's a block factor so the theorem
tells you in particular there are no
block factor colorings on Z because you
have to have at least this Tala function
tailed you certainly can't have are
bounded now there's another definition
though a stationary process is
k-dependent if things at distance k are
independent of each other so everything
to the left of the origin is independent
of everything to the right of k so k
block factor implies k-dependent maybe
maybe it's k minus 1 dependent doesn't
Lee and and there's it was this was an
open question for quite a long time I
that was the converse implication hold
here are there any processes stationary
processes the decay dependent and do not
arise as block factors so it was sort of
open for about 30 years but then people
found counter examples and and sort of
all the counter examples people found
were quite strange and they have the
feeling of things specifically conduct
constructed as counter examples so it's
a sort of long standing question is are
there any natural processes or is it
really for all processes that really
arise in practice these two equal well
it turns out that coloring
provides a very nice answer to this so
there's no block factor coloring of Z
but it turns out there is a k-dependent
coloring of Z in fact there's a one
dependent for coloring of Z a stationary
one dependent for calling this is very
surprising and a very very strange
process and and there's no one dependent
three coloring and there is a two
dependent for you going and this is
joint work with prompt Liggett so I
should stop it questions so maybe a
quick efficient was what's the largest
density of an independent set that
you've been building this way on the c2
yes this is half of the bond percolation
threshold and a little hot Wars it's a
lot of the clusters have slightly more
you know black converted black sites
than white sites or something much
bigger than the quarters is a pathetic
better than one of the color classes huh
uh-huh right do you think what you would
it be interesting to try to prove upper
and lower bounds on yeah I think I mean
and you get to play with the coding
radius as well of course I mean so so I
mean Oh with exponential tales yeah I
haven't thought specifically about that
but but yeah so it's a very you could
use a three-color rings together through
that's right that's right ma'am yeah and
actually yes or no thinking about it I
guess you can yeah I'm sorry we having
thought about it for those seconds look
I think or at least on Z D with even
with tower function tales you can get
arbitrarily close I think to the maximum
because
once you have a for coloring you could
do an awful lot just locally with block
factor so you can sort of divided into
big grains and just do exactly what you
want in the middle of each rotten and
then the boundary will do something so i
think see that particular question i
think dance to do but but maybe is but
it's a very interesting direction and
their questions like this on trees and
on d regular graphs that with slightly
different definition of locality that
have been looked at in a very
interesting this is maybe a related
question if instead of our secret to
define a tree with a given decay of you
asked for it to be approximate rocks
above all look so you said it it's in
some measurable function and you can get
to within probity are by looking in a
radius and yes but quite how i'm not
sure that it's yeah let me know that's
because I'm
local approximations of right yeah I
mean these things are all closely
related but slightly different I think
one more question to finish this um so
um thatís the the number of color
clashes that if the density is low it's
almost the same as the James to you
don't have to have a proper coloring Oh
somehow in some sense the so you're
allowed occasional errors yeah so that
sort of I mean depending on exactly what
question you ask then it there's a
version that sort of comes down to the
same thing more or less because if you
take one of these FF iid things and then
say okay if my radius turns out to be
bigger than a thousand I'll just forget
it and put something put anything there
you know then you will get that so at
least if you ask the question in that
way then it's sort of the same although
it's a bit I mean I guess it's a bit
harder at least from the point of view
of practically proving there's a bit
harder to actually construct an FFI ID
plus us where it works simultaneously
for all radii but to the mole is